welcome to the program we start with
breaking news coming out of new zealand
where police have shot dead a man after
he stabbed six people at a supermarket
the government's calling it an
isil-inspired attack authorities say the
attacker was a sri lankan national who'd
been in the country since 2011 and was
on a security watch list video posted
online showed panic shoppers fleeing the
scene at a shopping mall in the city of
auckland three of the injured are in a
critical condition
what happened today was despicable it
was hateful it was wrong
it was carried out by an individual
not a faith
not a culture
not an ethnicity
but an individual person who was gripped
by ideology that is not supported here
by anyone or any community
he alone carries the responsibility for
these acts
let that be where the judgment falls
jordan rudd is a journalist with
television new zealand joins me now from
the scene in auckland slight delay on
the line because of the satellite link
but jordan good to have you with us on
the program still a heavy police
presence at the scene of the attack so
the investigation continues
good evening that's right at 7 pm here
in new zealand and emergency services
were called here just after 2 30 and as
you mentioned there's still a heavy
police presence at this countdown
supermarket in west auckland one of new
zealand's it is new zealand's largest
city to my left and to my right that
this is a main street we're on and both
ends are cordoned off with police lights
flashing and as you can
probably see behind me
there are police carrying out
investigations as to what happened today
and it was chaotic scenes when we got
here shortly after 2 30 there were
people running there were cars whizzing
around the streets and people didn't
know what was going on and most notably
the sound of sirens echoing out around
the region there was confusion too
people didn't know what was going on
they were asking me do you know what's
happening they were taking videos and
they didn't actually know what they were
recording that was until cars started
filing out of this main car park here
and the people in those cars started
sharing their stories as to the shocking
scene they had just witnessed now
tonight there are six people across
three auckland hospital three of those
are in a critical condition the other
three
moderate
so as you can see police are remaining
here and probably will be very late into
the night to try and piece together
exactly what's happened indeed the prime
minister has already made a statement uh
in front of sort of national television
the authorities seem very clear on their
actions but there are still many
questions that remain unanswered
that's right the prime minister jacinda
arduin came out very strong saying this
terrorist quote is an isis sympathizer
he was a known threat and has been since
2016 which is the reason why up until
now he's been under constant
surveillance he was considered a threat
to public safety after twice buying
large hunting knives and possessing
islamic state videos he'd only recently
been released from prison and like i
said was under that constant
surveillance now prime minister jacinda
arturn told the media now this which is
quite strong on this one that the attack
was carried out by an individual not a
faith not a culture not an ethnicity but
an individual person gripped by an
ideology that is not supported here by
anyone
back here all countdown and pharmacy
staff who were locked down in this mall
have come out
which was good to see all looking
visibly shaken
but now investigations continue
jordan from television new zealand
thanks very much for joining us from
auckland